denis emailed me Monday morning and I
did not have anything prepared so this
is kind of rough although I've been
talking about and thinking about this
topic for a long time as you will
shortly see so last time I was here
python was a pretty cool language I'm
still shocked that we're now number four
on the most conservative list of popular
languages and number one or two other
popularity ratings and Denis just asked
me how come Python is so popular I don't
actually know I have a wild guess which
is that data science has lifted all
boats
I don't do data science myself
I barely know what the pandas thing
looks like I'm sure several of you here
spend a lot of time with that so yay
Python but as always Python is easy to
read easy to learn easy to write but
that comes last actually and I should
actually call out my great mentor alum
bear mertens who in the late 70s early
80s designed a language named ABC that
was designed to be easy to read and
write and learn from for which I was one
of the four or so programmers tasked
with implementing ABC after three or
four years the project was cancelled for
lack of popularity and Python is really
just a remix of ABC with perhaps the
biggest difference being that ABC used
capital letters for
keywords as was sort of prevailing
fashion in the late 70s and before utter
things that sort of make python a good
thing for people it's it lets you write
short code but not so short that it
becomes cryptic and it comes with
batteries included there is a huge
standard library plus it's really easy
to put in different batteries better
batteries batteries I had never heard of
batteries I don't care about in the form
of third-party packages and Python as
well as everything in pythons ecosystem
pretty much is open source which makes
my work easier because I don't actually
have to do any of it anymore I just have
to say I'm the PD FL now oh let's just
do a quick poll who here is familiar
with coding in Python from sort of
regular ok that's almost everyone so I
don't really have to explain too much
about pythons pythons runtime type
system one of the reasons that Python is
concise is that you don't have to be
explicit about the types of your
variables arguments return types and
other things Python does all its typing
at runtime so from a compilers
perspective there's not much more you
can say about a typical name that occurs
in Python except that it is an object
this is true even if it's a very
primitive type like integer or a string
or floating-point number there are no
unboxed values in Python there is some
obscure library that will let you
manipulate unboxed values and
the data science world numpy arrays are
actually a raise of unboxed values but
everything is sort of demarcated by
api's that mean that the type system of
the language itself has no worries about
unboxed values it also has no
opportunities for efficient code
generation because the compiler just
doesn't know it's object-oriented it
supports multiple inheritance if you
really want to you can do crazy things
like write a function that computes a
list of classes and use that as the set
of base classes for your class you can
even create your own meta classes I'm
not going into too much detail here as I
mentioned there are no declarations as
such well the only type of declaration
is about the scope of a variable but
nothing about its type you just say def
add of a and B return a plus B and it
either works or it doesn't when you call
it also and a lot of people don't
appreciate this when they start using
Python variables are not actually really
variables in the sense that they are in
most other programming languages in
Python a variable is basically just a
dynamic binding in most places what the
user thinks of as a variable and what
the language actually goes to
considerable lengths to make you believe
is a variable is really just a key in a
dictionary and when you assign to that
variable under the hood it sets value in
that dictionary this is also why the the
origin at least of why you can delete
variables in Python now for local
variables in functions there are certain
constraints that make it possible for
the compiler to actually cheat and not
materialised that dictionary and in fact
just manipulate values as if there were
registers or something like that but for
the most part you can't actually tell
the difference you have to sort of
really try to use some introspection api
before you can tell oh hmm i guess in
this context there is no real dictionary
or you have to read the reference method
so unlike some other dynamically typed
languages in Python there is still a
certain level of type safety which comes
purely from the interpreter being
fastidious in doing type checks when
they matter when you try to add two
objects together and one of those
objects is an int and the other is a
float great we'll turn the int into a
float add the two floats and return the
float on the other hand if one of them
is an int and the other is a string and
we'll throw a type error now if you try
to multiply an int and a string together
you probably know what happens it's not
a type error you get a repeated string
other things that are interesting in the
type system that more or less follow
from all this the concept called duck
typing
I guess the technical term would be
structural type checking or structural
subtyping when you call a method on an
object it may or may not work if it if
it works you win if it doesn't work well
you have a bug in your program that's
the sort of the attitude which means
that you can do all sorts of interesting
things where you pass a function an
argument that has an attribute that is
actually a method and the function calls
that method and it will work for any
class that defines that particular
method there is no requirement to say
well the right method on files can be
called here but the right method on some
other object cannot be called even
though it happens to be called right
duck typing for the win people love it
with sort of some limitations also with
this dynamic type system comes a lot of
introspection if you want to know what
the attributes of the data attributes of
an object are you can ask for that
objects dunder dict attribute we
pronounce under-under as dunder if you
want to know what its type is you can
ask for its dunder class attribute if
you have a particular class and you want
to check whether it's the instance of
that class you can call is instance like
in most languages then there are all
sorts of interesting quirks where at
some point we added an interesting new
feature like a decorators context
managers descriptors a whole bunch of
stuff that is well defined but is not
apparent from the syntax of the language
or only marginally so so why do we like
dynamic typing or why do pythons users
in general like dynamic typing well less
typing finger typing means shorter code
less boring code you can use those
dynamic tricks to add a little touch of
excitement like if you have a function
that takes arbitrary keyword arguments
then you can also turn those arbitrary
keyword arguments into attributes of the
current instance of any instance in fact
although I wouldn't recommend it
necessarily why does this not lead to
terribly buggy programs because we also
have a culture in the Python world of
doing a lot of unit testing and other
types of tests
there I remember it's it's sort of
settled now
I think PI test is mostly one but like a
decade ago there was a battle of
different testing frameworks and there
was a good thing there was lots of
interesting developments were going on
and this was all open source stuff there
where I didn't really have to do much so
pop dynamic typing is clearly popular on
the other hand the static typing people
have not given up yet static typing
definitely catches bugs earlier at least
some bugs it clearly doesn't catch all
bugs with static typing you have a
little more confidence when you're
refactoring your code if you add an
extra argument to a method then static
typing will tell you when you forgot to
add an extra value to a call site in
addition and I call type declarations I
call them type annotations because
that's what we call them in Python now
that we sort of have them human readers
of large code bases the people who sort
of are hired to maintain a million lines
of code that they didn't write but
they're still going to be responsible
for fixing it or adding stuff to it
those humans really appreciate having
something that tells them what the types
of arguments of functions are and you
can say well we have documentation well
documentation doesn't always stay up to
date sadly I wish it was not so but it
turns out that it's really hard not to
get the type annotations keep the type
annotations up-to-date because the
compiler will tell you when they they
don't match the code and it turns out
static typing is also still pretty
popular
so there is this new concept well it was
new a decade ago although I I think I
only heard about it about four years ago
gradual typing in Python we typically
call it optional static typing it is a
technique for adding static typing to a
dynamic language that lets the user
basically mix and match statically typed
and dynamically typed parts of their
code now obviously this mean that if you
want to cheat you can just keep your
code dynamic and the compiler will not
catch you we're not into that kind of
bondage and bondage and discipline you
you're just shooting yourself in the
foot but if you want to have more
confidence about the correctness of your
code now perfect confidence but some
better confidence you if you want to
benefit from some of the benefits of
static typing including its popularity
you can start using type annotations in
your Python code now and sort of we've
developed this over the past half decade
and we found that it is actually a very
reasonable way to introduce typing into
a large dynamic code base Python is not
unique of course typescript
is exactly the same idea for JavaScript
and Facebook did the same thing for PHP
with hack so my part I just noticed it's
it's doubly open-source it's a type
checker for python it was developed in I
think starting in 2012 or so by a
Finnish guy in yoga lettuce lettuce
hello can never pronounce his name he
got a PhD from Cambridge Cambridge
England from that pretty
I remember he approached me at a Python
conference either in late 2012 or early
2013 and he said look I I have this
language that is sort of inspired by
Python but I've added static type
annotations to it in a gradual fashion
because that that was also part of it
and I've written a type checker and the
trans transpiler that turns that code
into Python code which you can then
execute I said wow that's great and how
many users do you expect to have well
you know the story about the typical
language developed by a PhD candidate
there's one user until the thesis has
been approved and I didn't come up with
that that that story that I heard that
from someone in the Haskell world anyway
I said but if you change your syntax
just a little bit let's start by turning
the angular brackets into square
brackets because angular brackets will
not work and we can change a few other
things and guess what you can actually
make your language a superset of Python
or maybe a subset am never never sure in
which direction this goes but you can
make it compatible with Python so you
don't need the transporation phase code
written in language X well language
mypie is valid Python code and will
execute and the Python interpreter will
execute it just fine and in fact the
Python interpreter will execute it at
the same speed as it would completely
unanimity
yuka thought about that and together we
sort of whipped up a plan
and after that and after I hired him at
Dropbox we started actually introducing
this in the Python community and we
started working on standardizing this
this happened in 2014-2015 with a very
contentious PAP 484 that takes existing
function annotation syntax in Python
them basically says henceforth function
annotations will be used for type
annotations because syntactically these
things already existed in Python that
was the sort of that hint I was giving
Yuka
but semantically there was never any
agreement on what they meant and sort of
when we entered when we started a Python
3 work there was also a very contentious
discussion about adding typing to Python
somehow and after sort of going around
that subject several times myself I
realized that we would never get
agreement at least not in time for time
for Python 3 oh and probably not in time
for Python 3 10 we would never get
agreement on exactly how those type
annotations should work but I said if we
just add a little bit of syntax without
giving it meaning then people can
experiment with assigning different
meanings to that syntax the big debate
by the way was about whether these type
annotations are just used for
correctness checking or whether they're
also used for runtime checking or
possibly even for code generation and it
turns out that you need sort of quite
different approaches for the different
different ideas and I wasn't sure that I
knew with what I wanted but I knew that
eventually we would want some
of type annotations well so that
happened because you could work tat
Dropbox
he started sort of playing with my PI
and Dropbox codebase during events
called hack week and in 2015 I think
after the second hack week where we
played with it we started introducing
annotations in the Dropbox codebase for
real fast forward to this year we now
have two million annotated lines of code
now how do you count that it means that
the total line count of the functions
that are annotated is about two million
this out of five or six million lines
total we currently have a four person
team including Yuka it's pretty popular
in fact we almost never hear anything
negative about this except about the
speed of the tooling or the speed of the
introduction of type annotations in the
remaining four megabytes million lines
of code we also because my PI is open
source and we kept it open source and we
aggressively developed it open source so
all the design discussions about how
should we solve this problem in my PI
the entire bug tracker everything in all
code reviews is done on github and as a
result of that we have quite a few
external contributors some of whom
occasionally get promoted to Cordell and
sometimes to Dropbox or we've also found
that Facebook adopted this Quora adopted
this lift adopted this there is an open
source chat bot named zu lip that
there's a Python code base of about 100
500 thousand lines of code that was
completely annotated over the course I
think of the previous summer
so anyway I think that's a pretty
healthy project the standardization
efforts also paid off because it's now
supported by other type checkers for
Python perhaps the most well-known of
which is PyCharm popular ide which has
its own code completion and type
checking engine but which supports the
same syntax that we introduced for my
pie
google has a static analysis tool that
will eventually help them port their I
don't know tens of millions of lines of
Python 2 code to Python 3 Facebook was
so excited that they wrote their own
type checker which they just recently
open sourced at the last Python last
month and then there is a component
which is sort of type stubs or
descriptions of the standard library and
third-party packages that haven't been
annotated that everybody shares and
contributes to so with the project
status out of the way let's start
showing some code and give some details
so an important requirement was that
there would not be changes to the Python
syntax which is where the existing
syntax for function annotations was
essential which is also of why I
convinced Yuka to change his angular
brackets to square brackets because it
turns out that in Python you can
overload array indexing or dictionary
indexing on anything including using
meta classes on types themselves so you
can sort of you can define the meaning
of list square
brackets in square record clothes as
this refers to a list of integers the
other requirements were that Python
itself should not slow down and should
not actually do anything with the types
so you can put all the annotations you
want in your code your code executes
exactly as if those annotations weren't
there and finally no transpilers
otherwise we would have a lot more
syntactic options but it would also be
incredibly hard to get people to adopt
this because transpilers only work if
all the tooling understands the sort of
the richer syntax that the transpiler
accepts and so I'm very happy that we
didn't go that way
so now here is a tiny bit of code I'm
not using a fixed width font because I
think that's old fashioned for slides
let's some a thing named X sorry X thing
named a we start with the total
initialize to zero we loop over all the
things in a and we add those things to
the total and then we return the total
well you can see that if a was a list of
integers or a list of floating-point
numbers or a list of or maybe a numpy
array of complex numbers it would all
make total sense
there are also things where it doesn't
make sense but that's okay like you
can't sum a list of strings this way
because the total is initialized to a
number number type so this is fine this
is also still fine in my pie but of
course is no type checked now let's add
an annotation so we add list square
brackets of in square bracket close and
arrow int 2 the function heading the
signature and that's the only change we
make
now the mypie checker has enough
information to figure out what's going
on and it will in fact say this is fine
because I don't have any examples with
bugs in them so the syntax for
annotations is named : type where type
can be any anything that will explain
soon return type is indicated using an
arrow I think there are few other
languages that loot use the same
notation it's definitely not very common
but Python is not unique I don't know
maybe maybe Python sort of inspired the
other language that they have this I
think rust uses the same notation and
Scala also uses square brackets for
generics this same function we could
annotate it differently for example with
lists of floats to float now if you're
still a Python to user this is the only
slide I'll spend on the Python 2 syntax
there is a Python 2 version of this
syntax which uses a comment that we call
a type comment pound type column and
then in this case types in parentheses
and in arrow for the return type note
that the type comment that does not
repeat the variable names there are the
argument names otherwise this does
exactly the same thing as the Python 3
version in fact you can write this even
in Python 3 why would we allow using
type comments in Python 3 to enable
people to write code that is type of
version neutral which is an incredibly
important property of code while you're
porting into Python 3 oh yeah a reminder
that we have about a year and a half
until Python 2 is officially unsupported
which doesn't mean that the world
suddenly will stop using it
okay so how does type inferencing work
this may be fairly basic a simple
example the sum of two integers for some
reason I assign the sum to an
intermediate local variable X and then
we return that and how does the type
checker go about sort of figuring out
what's going on well let's focus on the
line x equals a plus B so we start start
by looking up the types of a and B which
come from the signature so we know that
both a and B are ins then because we
have operator overloading we're looking
up the function
dunder add on integers I'm simplifying
things here if you know how binary
operators work in Python you know it's
much more complicated than the
complications don't don't add anything
to explaining the type inference so now
we have this dunder add method on the
type of a which so that is actually
installed under add can it be called
with an int darn-tootin it cam so what
does it return in that case because that
function could be overloaded and in fact
I believe it is because if you call it
with float it will magically also work
and return a float yes you call it with
an integer and int and that is the type
assigned to the variable X Y on the next
line return X we do a similar thing we
say well what is the type of X because
that's the entire expression it's int
because we just computed that on the
previous line is that the desired return
type for this function yes bingo okay
the whole function works there's a lot
more to this in particular I'm not
touching on the notion of context where
in some cases
if you have a variable of that whose
type is declared the declare type can
actually influence how we interpret the
the types occurring in the expression
that's being assigned to it that seemed
overly complicated it turns out it's
essential to deal with all sorts of
corner cases of Python I don't have time
to go more into that if I were ever want
to get to the end of this talk so then
we have the question well what what can
it type be I've shown a few very simple
examples int list of int well they're
only a very small number of atomic types
others are string and bytes well they're
not even atomic but they're sort of
common built-in types then we have
container types and those are in fact
not built-in because again for obscure
technical reasons you have to spell them
with a capital letter at least that's
how we made it so that you can use this
in versions of Python that were already
released before my PI was invented so
capital lists with square brackets is a
list of whatever occurs inside those
square brackets we also have sets
dictionaries have to type parameters
because of course there is a key type
and value type in Python unlike some
other languages where the key type is
always strength tuples are technically
not generic types but a special form for
example a tuple square bracket int in
wool is a three tuple there's also a way
to spell a tuple of a variable length
but I don't really like those guys
perhaps more useful than the concrete
container types are the abstract
container types like sequence and
mapping and mutable mapping and mutable
sequence
there's at least a dozen of those for
those that existing names already were
predefined in pythons collections dot
ABC module which is pretty old from the
first the first time we introduced
abstract base classes in Python for my
PI we basically sort of steal those
names and give them aggressively better
meanings then there are a bunch of
things that are not so regular there is
a type named any which means well for
this particular variable don't bother
checking the type because I'm going to
do nasty things to it
which perhaps you shouldn't do in a
perfectly well type program but in
practice in Python and sort of on the
path to gradual typing real
realistically that happens also Python
has a bunch of dynamic features that
when used sparingly are very useful then
there is a whole bunch of stuff that I
really don't want to get into much there
is optional which says it's either an X
or it's none very useful a very very
common sort of style of of using things
in Python even in untyped code how often
do you see if X is none then there is
Union which is well it could be you can
say union of intend stir it could either
be an integer or string then you have to
insert a runtime type check just like
you would do if the code was untyped
I'll get to those a little later there
is a callable type you can say well the
type must be none which is not very
useful for arguments but pretty popular
for return types obviously then there's
no return which means this thing never
returns it either loops forever or it
raises an exception
there's a couple of crazy things having
to do with strings and bytes and more
things named tuple type Dix a new type
that you can look up in the manual so of
course these steps can types can can be
combined here is a very verbose function
signature sequence of tuple of float and
float returning tuple of float and float
we can solve that with a type alias
which is just a Python assignment that
takes a type on the right like tuple a
float and float and assigns it to name
on left and my PI is smart enough to
realize oh this is not a regular
variable assignments this defines a type
that I can then use later and lo and
behold you can now write the signature
using list of Veck and Veck all pretty
standard stuff so escape hooks already
mentioned any a few times there are
other escape hooks there is a cast the
cast is completely unsafe maybe at some
point we should add a down cast to the
repertoire which actually checks that
you're doing a down cast and not just
casting to some random object other
types that's unrelated but we currently
don't have that we do have a cast which
is like the last resort my PI is
apparently confused about what the type
of notice we tell my PI don't worry I
know it's a list expression and then you
can use it as a list expression there is
also a different way to just suppress an
error that might by my give for example
if you import a module that my PI cannot
find you can put a type ignore on that
line and then my PI will not tell you
that it cannot find it however it will
create a variable at least in its
it's own representation of your program
it will say well they're there as a
variable that name setup tools that has
type ne and if you call a method on it
the return type is still any sure Rajan
a nobody I don't know that that there
are any Python implementations that that
run on such unusual platforms see Python
is portable as long as you have 8-bit
bytes and your integers are at least 32
bits and we're slowly entering a world
where we're not even caring about we
don't even care about integers or
pointers smaller than 64 bits there are
some other Python the implementations
jython which runs on the JVM aren't
Python I think is still in existence
which runs it on Microsoft's DRL I'm not
sure what the cast sort of could do
differently for other platforms I mean
this cast is not there to truncate bits
or anything it's really really there to
correct the type checker and that
whether the list expression example was
actually meant to be downcast but
there's not much difference generics
okay so we have generics I already
showed list of int and dict off well
here's a slightly more complicated
dictionary that has string keys and
tuples of two integers for values you
can also create generic type aliases you
need a type variable type variables are
one of the warts of the type system
because we didn't have
a way to to sort of introduce type
variables without pre declaring them so
you have to call a utility function to
create a type variable and you shouldn't
be playing dynamic tricks with that
because the type checker is not actually
ever executing your code the type
checker is just reading your code and
trying to guess what it means anyway so
we can create a generic type alias name
pair which is a tuple of two values that
have the same type and then we can
derive from that a type alias named Veck
which is a pair of floats and then we
can find the same add vectors function
again you can also define your own
generic classes which is much more
interesting stuff than using them again
you have to start with type variable and
then you creates you you start with
class statement stack plus stack your
base class must be generic of some type
variable now you can also include other
base fare base classes still so you can
have multiple inheritance from a
non-generic class or from a different
legionary class but basically you must
have generic of T in there now we have
an instance variable named data declared
in the class using Python field 6 and
later syntax we spent a lot of time
debating how we would introduce variable
declarations that were somewhat similar
to the function annotations that we
already have and we ended up introducing
syntax that does not use a new keyword
you just say variable name colon type
and that has worked out pretty well very
sort of short and pythonic before that
you would have to use a type comment on
a variable initializer anyway this is
your classic stack except I forgot the
full or empty method there is a push
that takes a T there's a pump that
returns a T for things that return
nothing you have to explicitly say
returns none and then on the right we
have little we create a stack so to
create the stack to instantiate that
generic class you have to first in Chet
instantiate
stack of T to stack of int and then you
have to call that to create an instance
there's some cashing there to make it
fast now you push an integer you can not
push a string at least they've made what
at runtime you can but if the type
checker catches you doing that it will
give you an error you can pop something
from that stack and then the inferred
type for that variable will certainly be
in an integer which you can prove to
yourself by sort of trying to do
something to it that you can do with
integers there's also a built-in
function in only in my PI revealed type
that will just print the type as an
error message that's really just for
debugging what are we getting to here
runtime type checks so when say you have
an optional and a function upper that
takes an optional string and apparently
there are some cases where we want to be
able to pass none into it and then we
want to get on an empty string back a
different version actually would also
return an optional string but let's say
well we want to always return a string
so the way you write that is if the
argument is actually a string we call
the upper method on it there's an
existing string method named upper but
of course you can't call that on none
otherwise if it's not a string we just
return an empty string
on the right is code that works the same
way except instead of using is instance
it just checks if it's none returned an
empty string that's actually more
idiomatic my PI understands both
versions equally well and it will will
understand that in one branch of the if
statement the type of the variable is
actually ster what do we have on the
bottom we have a similar case where we
check we take an an argument that could
be any object which you can express with
object and unlike any object does not
suppress any error messages so you can't
do anything with an object because the
type checker says object has no methods
well you can convert it to a string
that's about it
so if that object is an integer then we
add one to it and otherwise we just give
up and return zero on the right I have a
little helper function that takes an
optional int and returns a non-optional
int and at runtime it just throws an
assertion error when the argument is not
none sorry when the argument is none
again the type checker understands
things like is instance or is none or
even just false sort of a equals B or
just if a it understands those things in
assertions as well as in if statements
and it will do the right thing there so
that again that's those three statements
on the bottom right type check correctly
the required call will in fact raise an
assertion error if there's no key in
that dictionary D which is apparently
the functionality that we want for this
particular require function yeah
is that included in some sort of
specification or is that just how my eye
works and user has to understand that
like pyre might work differently no we
we have that that particular one we have
nailed down in that four eight four yeah
yep four eight four does not nail down
every corner case of the type system
unfortunately and there there are other
corner cases of inference where it
doesn't doesn't specify things
completely and unfortunately pyre and
why I give vastly different answers on
some program actually on many
interesting programs but my PI is sort
of the reference implementation at this
point and the pyre people are feeding us
sort of complaints and bug reports and
feature requests and I expect that they
will also send us requests to change the
status the standard let's see
so after pep for eight four good thing
you mentioned that we started sort of
evolving the type system a bit and
probably the biggest addition is
protocols or duck typing I'll try to
read through this example quickly there
is a log function that takes a message
and a file object and it appends a new
line to the string arguments and then
writes that thing to the file very
primitive logging function then there is
a class save which derives from the
stack class I defined previously just
for convenience and to show that you can
inherit from a generic class sort of
specializing it to a specific type
because save is no longer generic it is
a stack of strings that has has a write
method
so the write method just pushes that
message on the stack and I don't know
what happens to it after that so we're
creating more
those savers and we try to log to it now
if you run that code it will actually
work but if you try to type check it you
get a complaint from my PI saying that
save object nevermind that it has a
right method then and everything works
just fine it's not actually an instance
of IO of ster which is the very
elaborate type that defines the i/o
streams in Python which has like two
dozen methods write and read and read
line and read lines and read into is a
TTY way to many methods it's also
generic because you have files of
strings and files of bytes anyway the
type checking doesn't work well here so
we want a way to say accept anything
that has a write method
well actually accept anything that has a
write method that takes one argument
that is a string so here we go we define
a class writable and we writable and we
inherited from a predefined thing named
protocol we add a method to it the
method is complete dummy there's a path
there you can also literally use the
syntax dot dot dot instead of the pass
although that won't work if you're also
Python 2 compatible this is not a class
that you can instantiate this is a class
for putting in signatures so now we
change your log method and the rest of
the code is the same we change it to say
that the file argument is a writable
well since the only thing we do with it
is call it write method that works just
fine
and since that save class actually has a
write method of the correct signature
the last line the log call is actually
now correct
and this is how we deal with duck typing
there are a few details like in most
versions of the typing module you would
have to import protocols from a typing
extensions module but will smoothen that
out eventually
so the key thing to note here is that
writeable is not an abstract base class
because save does not in fact inherit
from writable so without protocols you
could only solve this by defining a
abstract base class that has the defines
the write method and modifying the i/o
class which is deep inside the standard
library to inherit from that writable
class we sort of we did this long ago in
the standard library for one or two very
popular duck type methods like there's a
hashable class there which if you check
dynamically is this thing hashable the
hat you can use that is instance law of
hashable and the hashable class
overloads the is instance behavior and
just checks is there a right is is there
a dunder hash method that stuff doesn't
really scale yes questions that it does
not that is really difficult because
that sort of my PI would need its own
interpreter that is able to execute all
the code in this instance or his
subclass overload method so we chose not
yet to go down that path future
generations will get some PhDs out of
that probably but that would that would
really not solve everything for
protocols it would certainly be a very
large stick to kill that particular
mouse poorly translated Dutch say okay
well glad you're all still with me here
so there are many details I didn't even
mention the typing module you can look
that up in the documentation I do want
to mention stub files and a thing called
type shed sometimes there is no source
code to annotate and where is my PI
going to get its type definitions from
this happens when the code is written in
C or C++ or Fortran sometimes there is
source code but it's too crusty or it's
read-only for some reason you don't want
to annotate it the standard library has
a lot of very crusty code that would not
be easy to annotate so my pie is
actually configured not to bother
reading the standard library it never
never reads any standard library code
and it doesn't read any install packet
third-party code either but it does read
a thing called type chat which is a
collection of stub modules that are
basically class definitions with empty
method bodies and function definitions
and constant definitions and few other
things but like it's in tactically valid
Python code it is not executable but it
has all the type annotations that are
necessary to make my PI understand
what's going on and so we start out with
like a stub for the built-ins module and
we have stubs for I would say at least a
third of the standard library that
doesn't sound like much but it's
definitely the most popular third and a
small number of popular third-party code
and I think I already mentioned this
this is also an open source collection
it's on github and it's actually shared
with all the other static type analyzers
for Python another thing I want to
mention briefly is
suppose you have a million lines of code
or maybe just 10,000 lines to start
small somewhat small how do you get that
stuff annotated if you point my pie at
10,000 lines of code that you wrote over
the past two years let alone five
million lines of code you wrote over the
past decade it's gonna throw a lot of
errors
it might even crash man in 2015 when we
started experimenting we thought we
fixed a lot of my pie crashes just
because that sort of the drop box code
was much richer in all the corner cases
of Python that it explored that any of
the test cases we had thought of at the
last icon in May in Cleveland was a good
talk by Greg price clear code at scale
aesthetic types at Zoo leap and Dropbox
which sort of explains step by step how
should you go about it my three point
summary of that is write some kind of
wrapper script that sort of invokes my
pie on the right set of files with the
right set of flags start annotating only
a small number of files in fact start
analyzing only a small number of files
at a time so you don't get overwhelmed
set up continuous integration so that
once you you have a fixed point where
you have zero errors for at least the
configuration that that you actually
have in that script you will keep your
developers or yourself if it's just you
honest and you don't introduce new type
failures and then I want to mention that
there is a config file where you can set
things like strict optional is true the
whole story I mentioned about optional
actually only works if you use strict
optional is true you can also say
disallow untyped calls which is useful
flag that tells my PI if I mean type
checked code and I see a call to a
method or function that has no
annotations flag that as an error by
default when anything that's uh Nana
kated is just seeing as a big blob of
Enys and when you call that it always
type checks fine and whatever it returns
is now inferred as also having type any
and that in many cases sort of
propagates through the rest of your code
or at least to the bottom of your
function or however far you you're using
the variable that captured that result
so by using disallow untyped calls you
can make my pilot pick here about that
particular situation there is like 30
more flags that effect all sorts of
things like where to look for modules
and a whole bunch more strictness Flags
oh yeah they're also you can specify
most of the flags differently for
different packages or modules so here's
a summary of the standardization effort
at 484 sort of was the result of a long
and painful discussion in the community
about well should we have type
annotations what should it look like
what should the syntax be in the end
that the sort of the mypie
design mostly prevailed it's definitely
not a complete standard you couldn't
start implementing a type checker from
just that specification and end up with
the useful type checker it would sort of
report errors for most interesting
Python programs the variable annotation
syntax was not in Python 3 when it was
created so we had a separate pep for
that and it's only available in 36 then
protocols were their own pep
we have another pet that lets you
publish stubs outside the type shed
collection because while type chat is a
really handy way to bootstrap you for
third party packages it really doesn't
scale to have everyone submit their
stubs to type chat in fact there are
many third-party packages that are not
very popular and commonly used and have
conflicting names so who's whose
packaging ends up in in type shed so the
answer is neither but each package can
publish their stubs with their package
or separate for as a separate package
and then their first thing that came out
of Facebook was for word references
which I didn't even mention here but
there are so much painful syntactically
and there's now a future import where
you can avoid most so that pain that's
actually it except for our questions I
have a bunch of handy links mypie long
wrangled org is really the only one you
have to memorize because all the others
are linked from there yeah how to
install it
tip 3 install my pie my pie itself of
course is a PI 3 program even though it
can analyze Python 2 code and here are
some more links to all the various bits
of tooling that I could remember this
afternoon including Peyer which is named
pyar check on github we have two of
everything it seems we have two
different packages that do run time type
collection which is something again
didn't mention at all but again when
you're annotating a large code base that
is already working and you've got unit
tests and everything it would be nice if
you could instrument your running
program with something that observes
every single function call and
logs what are the types of the arguments
and well it turns out there's not a
completely trivial problem so Dropbox
and Facebook came up with separate
solutions type checkers the lor so
questions heckling selfie requests
[Applause]
couldn't cram that into a slide either
the variant story is that there is a way
to say it's covariant invariant or
contravariant in each type variable you
could you you can have things that are
that have multiple type variables like
dictionary is invariant in both of its
type arguments on the other hand mapping
which is a read-only version of
dictionary is covariant in the value
type tigran's no that is definitely an
issue I refrained from showing a certain
example because of that currently it
doesn't seem to be a big deal because in
general people have already solved this
problem for untyped code which is kind
of a cop-out but that's sort of
realistically that's that's where we are
we are mostly adding annotations to
existing code and
like that stack example works just found
without find without ever being able to
instantiate tea obviously there are
other examples where it's not so easy
like that this the summing example would
be nice if you could create a new tea
but the problem is in Python you can't
always create a new instance of a class
without knowing the signature of its
constructor so we really don't I mean
Python just doesn't really lend itself
to doing something like that okay I'm
actually kind of curious how many cases
are there of things being removed from
we have not done it for that reason we
have removed things from type shed but
always for the reason that the module or
the package turned out to be hopelessly
dynamic and someone had contribute
partial stubs that caused more pain than
than being helpful
I expect that people will start sort of
taking their their own annotations in
their own hands that the
first example that that will happen I
think is the utter package or utters I
think you do import adder it's very
popular in certain circles it turns out
that adder is not easily typed using
this type system but my PI has a plug-in
mechanism which is currently still very
experimental but someone contributed a
plugin that lets you type classes
created with the help of utters
decorators after is incredibly dynamic
it's a class decorator and a bunch of
things you put in the class and suddenly
the class has an automatically generated
comparison constructor or a bunch of
other things maybe pickle support
hashing and because it's a class
decorator that sort of just adds methods
to the class my PI has no hopes of
understanding what's going on there so
when you instantiate an instance of
those class my PI is very sad or
actually the user is very sad so using
the plug-in we basically special case
Mike my PI so that it actually
understands what that class decorator
does in that particular case without
having a like a hole interpreter for for
class decorators built into my PI but
one of the first bits of feedback we got
was well adders is evolving there's
enters 1.7 and 1.8 and whatever comes
next and they're all different and now
we want to have different versions of
the plug-in that will happen there
they're sort of that we there there are
a couple of other packages for example
Jango where people are working
on a set of stubs and Pep 561 is coming
just in time so that's no Django stubs
will ever have to be placed into type
chat because Django can just publish its
own stubs and of course it can publish
different versions of the stubs for
different versions of Jenga which is
also the point sure
back to you well okay
it supports a tiny bit of magic just
enough to understand I believe yeah I'm
sure Dropbox uses some of those things
internally is that how they sort of
approach that sort of Dropbox is trying
to stay away from Jason not always
successfully this explains why we have a
protobuf plot let's not plug in well
it's a plug-in for the protobuf compiler
actually we don't have a good strategy
for Jason other than saying well you
have to write a verifier and verifier
should probably return objects of a same
class that can be fully typed if you
have a very basic JSON schema that isn't
recursive you can also use a thing
called type dict
which is a hack where you can tell my PI
well here's a type and it's just an
alias for type check it as
follows it should only have these five
keys and for the first key the type of
the value is that and for the second key
the type of the value is that and so on
and you have to only
index it with literals for the keys and
it turns out that there is a law of sort
of Perl code written in Python that uses
this approach and Jason often follows
that pattern as well but yeah that there
are definitely some some things that
could be done better for Jason in
particular well the DB API is purely a
runtime thing so it's too late because
all the type checking happens just by
reading your source code so I didn't yet
four databases we would probably have to
have some other way where you you sort
of you somehow get the database engine
to spit out the schema and then you have
a little translator that turns that
schema into a set of class definitions
that have annotations in them and then
you can use that yeah I'm afraid that
that is really out of scope for this
talk because I I have no idea what
you're talking about
sorry file a bug okay first off thank
you very much for the talk and I'll
admit I'm not a programmer so I'm not
qualified these are two philosophical
questions I was startled by what are
your slides saying the advantages of a
dynamically typed language including the
fact it's exciting power tool if black &
decker made a chainsaw with no safety
interlocks they could say was a real
fighting chainsaw but I don't think
that's what they were so the first
question is that a product should be
safe above all else and in retrospect do
you think it was a mistake to not have
this be strongly tight ethically tight
from the store that's that I don't know
I the anthropic principle for that if I
had created a statically typed language
I would have had to compete with C++ and
Java and I wouldn't be standing here
from the opposite perspective a product
that's easy to use or easy to jump onto
the bandwagon that looks appealing
that's fun that does have value because
otherwise it might just founder I don't
know how to balance the philosophy of
giving people what they want versus
giving people what they need doing what
they want persons pushing on them some
reason their consciousness and what
exactly it is it that they need I mean I
I also created a language that while
being dynamically typed was not easy to
set hold and apart from one corner of
the standard library whose only goal it
is to to sort of unsafely hook into see
you cannot segfault python easily from
within itself I mean you'd have to
basically rely on a bug and interpreter
both where the sites were declared
upfront but maybe one of your types was
treat this as a dynamic type such that
in special cases like calls to standard
IO or something the sharp uses that
approach I gotta admit I mean there
there is something to say for that
that idea in ABC there were no visible
type declarations but ABC was statically
typed the language design had to
compromise because there were sort of
there was a different operator for each
type basically like there was no
operator overloading because like plus
meant that both the arguments were
numbers period and then there was like
runtime stuff where oh well actually we
have different representations of
numbers like summer rationals and some
are floats and the floats have a bit
whether they were exact or not or
something but and then there was a
separate separate level in ABC where
suddenly everything was still dynamic
because you could sort of edit your code
and the system as designed did not have
sort of did not retype check every piece
of code in existence when you change one
function
[Applause]
you